uh what did your take you think he's
gonna be successful uh elon and buying
twitter yeah i mean he's world's richest
man i mean there's a price for
everything right yeah no i think he's
gonna buy twitter
how about 68. 78. eventually they're
gonna have to sell right because if you
put a high enough price it'll be against
it'll be in violation of the fiduciary
rules not to sell it i i mean i think
that they are getting pretty close if
they turn this down like somebody's
going to sue them so yeah someone will
sue them yeah right and whether they win
or not it's not going to matter but then
like if he just increases at a dollar
totally they deny it again like they've
got a child like what like here's my
argument would be like okay cool what do
you think the company's worth
right like if you're the twitter board
you keep saying no you can't possibly
think we're three times more than the
public market things yeah like it's just
there's some number and so if he doubles
it i think double is the threshold where
it becomes egregious if you say no no
yeah they're they're gonna have to say
if he really wants the asset he they're
gonna have to buy it it's a public
company right yeah i wonder how much
money he's made so far since he bought
it when it's up like twenty thirty
percent time out this might be a little
sketchy taking a position and then
coming up a week later and like with the
like basically an all-cash takeover
opportunity like that's a little sketchy
don't tell me you think he's trying to
do it to make money no no
but again i think he's doing it to send
a big fu to the sec and all these
regulators that keep trying to sort of
sign me as free speech and everything
it's almost like i can do whatever i
want bingo yeah exactly exactly it's
like it's not illegal
but it's not not illegal you know yeah
well and he did make it very clear that
if they don't accept it like he he gave
himself an out too if they don't accept
the offer i can't be a shareholder
because i don't think i can do what i
want to do oh yes
the price goes up he sells he makes
money people are going to have a heart
attack yeah when in reality he's like
guys look i you know i took a position i
thought i wanted a board seat now i
wanted the whole thing they said no what
do you want me to do by the way elon
musk is just doing what over schweinman
have been doing the whole time you know
he just does it very publicly and funny
in a hilarious manner we were just
talking about that the people that are
like oh we can't have our media channels
controlled by rich people it's like what
do you think it is
somebody said just fire the opinion
checkers
like to be completely honest twitter is
one of the only businesses where i
actually think the users could do a
better job running it than the executive
100 like like if you just crowdsource
which is what elon frankly has been
doing yo you all want to edit button
okay yeah would you all pay three
dollars if you didn't have to see ads
and have crypto spam like okay but he's
just running these polls and stuff and
when you look at it like the users are
so engaged i mean i went one time i
looked at my phone at like the screen
time yeah i spent way too much time on
twitter who doesn't right totally and so
you actually have a good feeling for it
and i bet you that the executives don't
spend as much time on twitter as many uh
be shocked there's a question does the
ceo of twitter or elon musk spend more
time on twitter elon musk with that
question
i would have to say yes right like so if
that's the case uh john you disagree nah
yeah from what it looks like he like
goes on twitter for like 20 30 minutes
stints fires off a bunch of tweets
total time but he certainly has what are
you guys talking about the last time
that the ceo of twitter tweeted was on
april 10th four days ago yeah and that
was that was about was rare hold on that
was that was before elon the time before
that was april 6th
and then the time before that uh
before he became the uh ceo was talking
about elon was march 16th come on that's
ridiculous
he would go almost a month from march
16th to april 4th he didn't tweet the
ceo of mcdonald's eats more mcdonald's
than that
i'm guessing he's about once a week who
is it i mean it's just crazy it's just
crazy hey you did you like this video
great we make five of them a day and
post them here on this channel make sure
you subscribe like the video and see you
next time